what do you think people get wrong about
reinvention like what is it that the
people who fail to turn their life
around do I think people think it's a
magic trick they snap their fingers they
make a decision and their life is
different overnight I think there's a
lack of appreciation of everything that
goes into the moment where you change
your mind and you do something different
and then all of the work that goes into
that rebuilding phase in the aftermath
of making that decision that ultimately
creates the new life I think people are
impatient they want results too quickly
they don't appreciate the amount of hard
work that goes into actually crafting
the life of your desires and I think as
a result of that when they don't see
results immediately they burn out and
Retreat to what's safe versus welcoming
failure welcoming uncertainty getting
comfortable with risk and remaining
persistent in their Vision to create
something more in alignment with their
authentic self